alors voilà depuis que je suis petit
j'ai un problème c'est que je n'arrive
pas à répondre à cette question qu'est
ce que tu veux faire plus tard comme
métier donc à la maternelle
je leur ai dit de patienter en primaire
je me suis dit tiens je vais leur dire
je veux être mon pied pour un petit peu
calmé le jeu puis cette fameuse réunion
de 24e où on m'a obligé à trouver donc
un cursus et là j'étais un cap de leur
dire ce que je voulais faire ce que je
ne savais pas à l'époque
en fait c'est que j'allais devoir
inventer mon métier passionné de musique
depuis le plus jeune âge j'ai décidé
donc de m'orienter vers la musique
j'ai été dix caire puis grossistes pour
les disquaires et ensuite j'ai décidé de
m'orienter vers la musique je suis
devenu dj je suis devenu musicien et
j'ai commencé à acheter des
synthétiseurs des années 90 les années
80 des années 70 jusqu'à cet achat d'un
theremin un synthétiseur qui date des
années 20 ans synthétiseur russe qui est
une petite boîte avec deux antennes et
synthétiseurs faisait des sons assez
fantomatique
vous avez peut-être déjà entendu ce
synthétiseur dans les films de science
fiction des années 50
à partir de ce moment là j'étais
confronté à un autre problème c'est que
mes amis quand il voulait aller à la mer
ou autour d'un feu de camp pour aller
jouer
prenez leurs guitares rené leur
harmonica leurs djembés et moi j'avais
des câbles des effets des synthétiseurs
et sans électricité j'étais absolument
bon à rien de là j'ai commencé à
réfléchir un synthétiseur acoustique et
la scie musicale est vite devenu une
évidence pour moi donc j'ai commencé à
rechercher ou m'acheter une scie
musicale et ce n'était pas évident parce
qu'on ne trouvait pas d'instrument cette
époque je n'avais aucun aucune idée d'où
je pouvais trouver cet instrument donc
j'ai commencé à faire des recherches et
pendant neuf mois j'ai travaillé sur les
aciers j'ai travaillé sur l'acoustique
lui j'ai fait des recherches à paris sur
les brevets et un peu à la fois j'ai
réussi à recréer cet instrument qui
était un peu tombé dans l'oubli
très rapidement j'ai des musiciens qui
sont intéressés à mon travail et m'ont
demandé de jouer pour eux leur fournir
des instruments et je me suis retrouvé
assez rapidement a joué au théâtre
antique de fourvière avec benjamin
biolay ou même à la salle pleyel à paris
avec emilie simon et c'est vite devenu
une passion pour moi est une évidence
que cet instrument était vraiment fait
pour moi alors peut-être que je peux
vous vous faire voir un peu à quoi
ressemble cet instrument pour vous
puissiez juger du son un peu envoûtant
cas ce dangereuse instruments
oh
non
et
oh
donc voilà vous avez peut-être entendu
cette onde sonore
alors c'est une union jin choi dalle
c'est à dire que c'est le bruit de l'eau
finalement qu'il énonce initiaux idal et
comme notre corps est composé à 80%
d'eau ça touche énormément certaines
personnes il y en a d'autres qui ne
supportent pas du tout le son de cet
instrument
mais comment cet instrument vous touche
il vous touche profondément
car vraiment il fait résonner des choses
en nous enfin voilà voici une des
applications donc de cet instrument
alors moi j'aime beaucoup la musique
électronique donc j'ai choisi de faire
quelque chose de très éthéré de très
calme mais il est également utilisé dans
de nombreux styles différents tels que
la chanson en chanson française
notamment en chansons réalistes par
exemple comme olivia ruiz la tordue les
ogres de barback utilisent cet
instrument on l'utilisé également
musique religieuse car c'est très joli
avec un écho dans une église dans divers
styles aux usa aussi maintenant la
country reprend cet instrument les
musiciens expérimentaux aime beaucoup
aussi triturer les secondes cet
instrument
et les prochaines applications je pense
que ça pourra aussi être en musique
méditative des choses comme ça car
toutes les fréquences étant présente
dans cet instrument on peut très bien
avoir des fréquences qui font du bien
enfin voilà donc les applications sont
très variées et diverses
alors peut-être vous demander d'où vient
cet instrument en fait au départ ce sont
des bûcherons
on dit parfois au canada ou en argentine
qui lorsqu'ils ont aiguisé leur
instrument se sont rendus compte que en
le tenant d'une façon particulière et en
les élisant vous arrivez à générer du
son et en modulant donc l'attention de
l'instrument il faisait changer les sons
et donc produisent et de la musique
donc quelqu'un un peu un peu plus malin
s'est dit je vais essayer avec un archet
et la scie musicale était né
donc cet instrument devint très vite
populaire parmi dans le monde du cirque
les clowns l'utilisèrent beaucoup dans
le vaudeville jusqu'en 1914 en 1914
l'acier se faisant plus rares les hommes
étant parti à la guerre
cet instrument tomba dans l'oubli très
rapidement et on n'entendait plus parler
jusque dans les années 50 où un français
jacques keller décida de s'y intéresser
à nouveau
il transforme à cet instrument qui au
départ était un outil en un véritable
instrument de musique en y ajoutant une
poignée d'inflexion en y ajoutant une
crosse ergonomique il enleva les dents
de la cie pour avoir un meilleur son et
il découpe à la scie dans le sens du
laminage de l'acier ce qui permis une
amélioration conséquente et des
instruments qui allaient jusqu'à 3
octaves à l'époque comment fonctionne
une scie en fait c'est un idiot phone
c'est à dire que c'est un instrument qui
génère son sont par tapotements ou par
frottement comme un glockenspiel qui est
un xylophone métallique ou une cymbale
de batterie il me suffit donc à la
différence du xylophone c'est que cet
instrument ne
ne comporte pas de petites lamelles qui
différencie les notes toutes les notes
étant les unes à côté des autres
il me suffit donc de faire une petite
torsion sur l'instrument pour pouvoir
mettre en vibration une lamelle de métal
qui correspond à une note
les notes et plus grave étant à
l'endroit où la ciel plus large
les notes médium au milieu et les notes
aiguës
bien sûr là où l'instrument est le plus
fin donc voilà excusez moi j'ai un trou
donc on peut aussi jouer en duo phonie
c'est-à-dire module est l'instrument en
jouant des harmonies imiter le cri des
oiseaux comme ceci ou même module et un
son dans les graves
jusqu'au réseau comme ceci donc depuis
dix ans je m'attelle à améliorer cet
instrument puisque je suis partie des
brevets initiaux et je suis maintenant
arriver à faire des instruments qui font
quatre octaves
donc je peux peut-être essayé pour
terminer cette petite présentation de la
scie musicale de partir sur quelques
notes de piano et vous faire une
deuxième petite démonstration
voilà
beaucoup
où
voix
moi